We have a voicemail number, which is two one
nine two David P. This is OK.
So this is the voicemail from the San Antonio
Troll, and he's calling with a cutesy little
fake accent.
But he actually brings up some interesting
aspects that just, again, prove the degree
of lack of understanding that a lot of these
people have.
Now, the San Antonio troll has been calling
multiple times a week for months trying to
get on.
And I'm just so bored with him that I've not
been playing his voicemails.
But there's actually something instructive
here.
So let's listen and then discuss.
Hello, Mom.
My name's Tommy.
I'm a long time.
Listen, I love your show.
Thank you, Pokemon.
I like a lot of Progressive's.
When you have the best ideas, they're better
than everything.
Just throw their ideas.
All of the ideas that I know you agree with
me on this, but what I'm thinking as a progressive,
you know, a lot of these racist right wingers,
all racist, they've been that the you know,
that we will do as I say, not as I do.
We should prove them wrong, you know, how
for reparations or for higher taxes or for
staying home and not working.
Why don't you stop working and only collect
the coalition?
Why don't you pay higher taxes out of your
paycheck?
And why don't you pay reparations?
I think if we do that, if we do it first,
then other people like our great stuff.
I don't know it even so.
This is I mean, obviously, this person is
very, very dumb.
But what's interesting about it is that there
there are people on the.
Right, who seem to not understand the point
of society and government and and culture
and what constitutes policy, so that's a very
you know, David, if you which I don't if you
think people shouldn't work and should just
get covid money, why don't you stop working
and get just live off of covid money?
Well, first of all, I didn't get any covid
money.
I didn't qualify for any covid money.
That's first of all.
So I didn't get any money from anybody for
first and foremost.
Secondly, why don't I just choose to pay more
taxes?
That's not policy.
Meet me.
Choosing to pay more taxes changes absolutely
nothing.
That's not how we govern.
That's not how modern societies make decisions.
Me saying I'm going to send the IRS more money,
which will mostly go to defense spending anyway,
that's not policy and that's not how adults
actually govern.
And then why don't I pay reparations?
I mean, I don't need that.
One of the trademarks of the San Antonio TROL
is reacting to things I've not said.
I've not advocated for people to start paying
reparations.
I've said that I think it's a politically
difficult thing and my my views on it are
not set in stone.
But this is not a show that has started saying
people start paying reparations.
So it's really important to understand.
And, you know, I know that I'm taking total
idiocy and trying to actually analyze it,
but there is something in there that's important,
which is if you believe the tax rate should
be X, why don't you just start paying that
tax rate?
And that is mind numbingly naive and also
extraordinarily childish in the context of
that is not the way a society decides what
its priorities are.
And, you know, I'm not trying to convince
the San Antonio troll, but I think it's important
to keep this in mind.
We have a great bonus show for you today,
stickers that signal whether you've been vaccinated
from covid.
That could be the future.
And we're going to talk about that number
two, who did really well economically in 2020.
We know like the Uber billionaires did really
well, but it's actually bigger than that.
And we're going to talk about that on the
bonus show.
And major development in the world of electric
vehicles.
Toyota has a game changing new car battery
that is building on the successes we've already
seen from Tesla and others.
And we could be looking in the next five years
at extraordinarily dramatic changes in terms
of range and charging speed and capacity for
electric vehicles, which is exactly what it
might take to get electric vehicle adoption
to the next level and bring down prices, which
is also very important.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
And I will tell you about today's insane tech
disaster, which hopefully you didn't notice.
We actually had one of the biggest tech disasters
today in the last probably two years of the
show.
And I think we cleaned it up pretty well.
So I'll talk about that on the bonus show
as well.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
Join Pakman dot com.